hello everyone thank you so much for
coming
my name is second Dugan I'm the director
of the communications forum before we
start there is a sign-up sheet over
there on that table with a writing
utensil on top of it we do these events
six times a year three times per
semester and if you put your name down
on that list we will only email you for
those events we will not email you for
anything else or give your email away to
anyone else so if you want to find out
about these events that is a very
effective way to do that tonight's event
will function like all recognition to
arms
they'll be will start out with a
moderated conversation and then we will
go to an audience Q&A we also have three
of Emily's books on sale here and as
someone who has read all three of them I
can attest that they are all great and
well worth your time and money
so please buy away afterwards so Kevin
Young is an old friend of mine and the
poetry editor of The New Yorker and the
director of the Schomburg Center for
Research and black culture at the New
York Public Library he's the author or
frightening Lee of 13 books of poetry
and prose selected 9 placket poems from
1999 2015 which is long the super
National Book Award his 2003 poetry
collection jellyroll
a blues was a finalist for the National
Book Award and the net Los Angeles Times
books Book Prize and his most recently
nonfiction book is bunk
the rise of hoaxes humbug plagiarist
phonies post facts and fake news and it
was also long listed for the National
Book Award and was a
with the National Book Critics Circle
Carol Bell is an assistant professor of
communication studies and affiliated
faculty and political science at
Northeastern University Val's teaching
and research focuses on the
intersections of media politics public
opinion and public policy with a
particular focus on issues of social
identity her first book the politics of
interracial romance in American film is
forthcoming from college this
communication forum is also sponsored by
radius at MIT for which we are very
grateful thank you so much for coming
out and thank you for being here thanks
for having me I'm excited to talk about
this book okay
PG burnin but it also feels strangely
timely but given how much history there
is in this book I know that you don't
start writing it yesterday so can you
talk a little bit about when you did get
the first idea when you first had the
idea first became interested in hoaxes
and then first sort of like decided to
actually write about it oh well yeah
thank you it's so good to see you and
thanks Seth for inviting me and Seth
actually makes an appearance in the book
not as a hoaxer but as a cover of hoaxes
which I'm sure will mention but in a way
I was interested way we all are in kind
of fakers and Kahneman which is I think
a very American thing I started writing
in earnest what became the book I guess
about six years ago when I had finished
the grey album and part of that you know
book was thinking about lying as a
positive thing lying as part of
african-american culture and by that I
mean that lies in black culture are
another one named for folk tales like we
were up late last night telling lies and
Zora Neale Hurston writes about that and
so does Ralph Ellison and so I had
thought about that a lot and the way
the correspondence what I end up calling
the storying tradition this idea of
telling a story because in Louisiana and
my mom's here so give a wave Wow
Louisiana's own and and that's Matapan
and JP's own but you know if you're down
in Louisiana you couldn't say to your
cousin much less have grown up like you
lie you would have to say you story and
so I started thinking about that you
know what's it mean to story and Louis
Armstrong Solo tells a story and so this
idea of storing as improvisation but the
one I finished that I realized that
there was you know a bad side to lying
apparently and so I I had these these
sort of ruminations on fake memoirs
especially and I started thinking well
what our fake memoir is really about
because people often say hoaxes or
fakery is about sort of this blurry line
between fact and fiction which I always
thought was bunk and I realized that
they were about something else and
something more nefarious and sadly
something more American which is to say
race and so that's how I started
thinking in earnest like there's ways to
go back even further than that but
that's how I started writing about six
seven years ago now it's interesting
you're talking about how lies or
storytelling is part of American culture
but when I think about it I also think
about the place of lies and sort of like
an outsider telling the story of
Africans right or which is a lot of what
happens here but before you move on to
that can you talk a little bit about
that first inspiration sort of years ago
yeah I mean in college I worked let's go
as part of Harvard and adding this
Travel Guide which of course you know
facts really matter and you'd get
letters from people that said like we
were number one in the listing for you
know Taos and now we're number two and
I've lost a million dollar you know I
was like this crazy power you had just
by ranking people so you took it really
seriously meanwhile there was a managing
editor at the time and he came in one
day and he said you know I have cancer
bro
and we were very upset you know everyone
was didn't know what to do and his head
was like ball like two days later and
looking back on his like that's not how
it works if you have chemo or cancer and
then he went on I learned later to hoax
a lot of people he pledged money he
hoaxed Slate Magazine a couple times he
hoaxed the University of Oregon
promising tens of millions of dollars
that he didn't give though they threw
him a big party and so I realized just
going back that you know we had known
this hoaxer and it really brought home
personally how that what I call D
hoaxing in the book process is really a
shock to the system
and so you know you have to filter back
through and I was like oh wait so I know
he was lying about X Y & Z was he lying
about cancer you know and that I think
that kind of destabilization also was
somewhere behind that and he used to
open the book within now he's in the
middle so that's another interesting
point so the book actually starts with
PT Barnum's
so at one point in the process did you
ship because he become such an essential
central character in this so how did
that come about yeah I think it really
helped to realize that there would be
these characters in the book I think at
one point it happened in the middle you
know and I realized that I think I was
fighting a long time that it was a
history and that was kind of wild to
realize that it was this history and not
just you know a story of a bunch of
different hoaxes and I was really
resistant to it just because I I'm not a
historian I didn't feel like that meant
something else to me but what it really
helped is once I realized that is that I
got to tell the story of the hoax and
really the kind of biography of an idea
and the fact that now it's biography is
wildly everywhere you know is an
interesting thing I was just riding over
here in the cab and watching on our
little tyrannical devices
you know a rant about fake news from
someone's president so we'll get to that
and it started with Barnum and that
really helped because I realized it was
an American story it was a story that
you know had a lot to do with
entertainment with what he called humbug
but then also had to do with where we
are now so PT Barnum is most famous for
spectacle for being a great showman but
in this book you know I'm sort of
embarrassed to realize that I had only
known him for that and that I had you
know honestly one of my earliest
memories is going to the circus Barnum
and Bailey Circus with my dad and after
reading this I felt almost really
ambivalence and almost a shame that I
didn't know this other side of him but
of course there's a reason right I don't
know this other side of him so could you
talk a little bit about historian and
how there's sort of the role that he
plays yeah Barnum I think it's
fascinating figure I mean he is I think
still one of the greatest entertainers
and certainly captured something about
American life start in the nineteenth
century and the fact that he lives so
long across the century and worked so
long I think gives rise to a lot of
things I mean he pretty much invented
the circus he certainly changed the the
museum which is to be a kind of private
enterprise to the kind of public
enterprise we think of though a museum
and Barnum's day he had a thing called
the American Museum which he maintained
for a long time and partially he bought
that from a gentleman named Peale who's
been peels Museum was sort of the first
trying to show Natural History and the
advance of civilization and he almost
kind of purposely he had to buy fields
Museum and then he just dis assembled it
over time kind of like cannibalizing the
father kind of thing and you know what
interested me is he was such a huge
figure but that also a lot of his most
famous first show exhibit if you will
was Joyce half a woman who as you may
know was
claimed to be George Washington's
nursemaid
this is 1835 which would have made her
161 years old which he proclaims there's
a handbill for that in the book which I
own and you know it says really
remarkable things about her and what I
think is interesting is it depicts her
as a remarkable thing being you know
sometimes people would say oh she's made
of rubber you know and then well I think
it's brilliant my Barnabas he would
incorporate any critique or question
into the show is she made of rubber come
see you know she's an automaton Oh is
she you know is she real in different
states he would sort of think about
whether she was free or not this was we
think so yeah I mean certainly we think
that Barnaby certainly had been enslaved
and we think Barnum purchased her
there's also stories that he might have
taken out her teeth to make her look
older you know it's a troubling moment
but at the same time there was this
notion that she was honored at least in
part by being connected to the father of
our nation and people want to touch him
through her that has its own problems
but it is a different view then I think
even later in the century for Barnum
himself so here's Joyce half this figure
of perhaps ambivalence but also of honor
and then when she died
Barnum brought her body back to New York
and had her excuse me autopsy did a
medical theater for money people charged
admission with that he then revealed of
course that she was abnormal advanced
age and then he said well you know we've
all been hoaxed kind of you know very I
think not to me is the most troubling
thing is that he you know alive or dead
he owns her and anything that she does
whether she's a slave or not it is owned
by him and any form of the story and we
can kind of see how that plays out now
and that stories you know get stolen get
borrowed get taken the book ends with
sort of plagiarism writ large but also
this way that you know Barnum I think
was really drew
at incorporating the hot-button issues
of the day because here we are in 1835
slavery is at the center of life there's
a question of course of George
Washington is now becoming a cult he and
one show is embodying this American
history and he would go on to do that
with his sort of later show called what
is it which we can talk about right so
if that if it had only been about choice
half in terms of his relationship to
displaying black people enslave people
as sort of you know curiosity and even
you know her autopsy is another sort of
like shocking oh yeah moment of
exploitation in which you know thousand
people or something I think you reported
watched her right so he's making this
tremendous money but that wasn't the end
of his use and exploitation of
african-american people and it was they
were African American novels right but
he for the other people he said that
they were not right oh yeah I mean you
know it's a it's a I became really
fascinated by sideshow culture and the
sideshow as a facet of American life and
Barnum you know did not invent the
sideshow he perfected it and so in the
1830s he comes to kind of perfect what
and I think his genius was to take
things that might have been the sideshow
and then put him in a museum setting and
by museum you know there would be an
operetta there'd be like lovely fountain
and then there'd be you know like a
two-headed monster
so you know he really was able to kind
of create this this sense of all these
things as family entertainment and we
should understand that that it wasn't
like you know a specialized thing a
sideshow was the whole family would see
what at the time was seen as kind of
wonder what these kind of miraculous
births of people born different you know
did have a kind of place they were
called monsters but not in the sense
that we have now but monsters as a
creation of God's wonder or prodigies is
another name for for such births and
those people often found lives careers
money as sideshow entertainers
and so it wasn't strange for people to
have been displayed in this way I think
Barnum perfected that and made it you
know doesn't she seem to say the
sideshow doesn't have a troubling
history but we do have to grapple with
that and the our attraction to that and
I think he sort of centralized that but
it is true that the stories he then told
become really troubling because he would
take normal people unquote and make them
exotic just by being black or brown or
whatever or slightly different he would
claim they're from Australia or claim
they're from the wilds of deepest Africa
and the person he did this I think the
worst with is a figure named what is it
so it's capital IT question mark well
and one of the things I stress in the
book and I found this in Harvard's
archives I had suspected that it was not
what is it but what is it
but in Harvard's archive in one of the
Harvard librarians is here who helped me
okay so you know like it was really
amazing to find he's on the cover of the
book his name is William Johnston he's
on the right here and he's on the inside
you can see him not you know designed
but what I think is amazing about him is
that he was pictured by Barnum in 1860
right after Origin of Species as the
missing link you know so what is it
you're supposed to go in and see and
judge for yourself and this troubling
kind of form of democracy that he
created I think is really telling and I
think he offered up this idea that
anyone could be an expert and you too
could decide for yourself is this person
human is this what is this being and in
fact it's not even a being it's an it
you know and I think that troubling
language is a lot of the problem but as
I trace in the book he has a kind of
interesting afterlife and goes on to
interesting things and one of the
figures is sort of in a petting tusu
type well I'm you know certainly Joice
Heth was handled and touch I don't know
how close you would get to what is
actually he's usually depicted in in a
kind of caricature form I think he were
just viewing him because he was wearing
a furry suit you know I mean like you
weren't I don't think you would get the
same like what is the right term like
like no electric charge from being that
close to that person first you're
supposed to be ferocious yeah yeah he
was kind of ferocious but you'd go in
and have like a stick and stand in there
and I think the thing that's fascinating
to me is part of even people reclaiming
him and thinking about him in a new way
was talking about him as being
microcephalic and my conviction is that
he wasn't even that and at the end of
this box I saw at Harvard there he was
smiling at us and I don't picture that
in the book but and he just looks like a
dude with a weird haircut yeah and you
realize like it's a little like Emmett
Till in all seriousness where you know
even in our reclaiming narrative we kind
of assume that Emmett Till maybe he did
something right you know like we can't
just let go and say you know maybe those
dudes in Starbucks just I mean I don't
have that but you know there's a
dominant there and maybe he had there
was some reason that Barnum could make
him in it and the truth is that I think
he was just a performer and he famously
says at the end of his life we'll we
fooled them a long time didn't we he
lived 65 more years after this so he
lived a good long while and he was seen
by something like over a hundred million
people by the end of his life so really
a lot of Barnum's reputation and wealth
came from this sort of the way he
treated race right and oh yeah this way
but we don't really remember any of that
well we remember quotes that he might
not have said like it there's a sucker
born every minute
my favorite quote which he did say is
there's a every crowd has a silver
lining which is one of my favorite
and I think that crowd Ness is big part
of his appeal and a big part of why
we're in this for fake news moment he
appealed to the kind of crowd
sensibility and he let you as
individuals feel like you were making
your own discernments but he really
played to the crowd in a broad way and
that you too could participate and you
know it was a little like being at a
rally or something you could participate
and feel like you're making your own
individual choice but really he was
guiding you to the your decisions and he
was shaping your story he would famously
at the end of his show say this way to
the egress and if you thought it was
another show there you'd be outside all
right
so bunk the title yes there's an
interesting story behind that another
thing sure copy so nice man so one of
the many things I learned was that that
term right so much so many of these
hoaxes do have these political
underpinnings you know certainly
Barnum's work with freaks and with
blackness couldn't have existed without
the ideologies the underpinning
ideologies that you know fits so well
and sort of with the American story
but it was interesting that that even
the term buck originated and sort of
political discourse tell us a little bit
about it yeah it comes from the Missouri
Compromise in 1820 and this someone from
the House of Representatives floor the
question has been called everything
settled of course to make Missouri a
slave state and this person says well I
need to give one more speech and they
say look we're done you know you don't
need to he says I need to give a speech
to Buncombe being his home County which
is actually where Asheville North
Carolina is so it's a beautiful place I
can see why I wanted to say that but
that quickly became Buncombe bu and Kay
um because it's bun comb and then it
became bunk and it just meant political
you know muckety-muck yeah signaling for
pre nonsense
yeah like kind of extended BS now with
but it has a political and racial origin
and so when I presented itself as a
title which was pretty late in the book
and had another bad title for a long
time yeah okay I won't tell it they
really made sense because it's such an
American word and you know again I was
interested in this as an American
phenomenon I mean it's funny because
there were no cameras back then in in
that hall but you know politicians do
that sort of thing that sounds a very
like a very modern thing to do oh yeah
people doing for season yeah why would
you stop right okay so one of the things
that I thought was really interesting
also was that it seems like you're
making not just a history but kind of a
typology there are a lot of different
types of falsehood that are in this but
could you talk a little bit about some
of the distinctions and the
commonalities and yeah I was interested
in Barnum's definition of humbug because
he really is trying to get us to think
about
humbug not as you know true or something
like that by no means he's he's
admitting that he's the prince of humbug
but a humbug means a good show like
you're being fooled but well you know if
the person is a bad fake even or even
like a good fake but not a good show
that's a bad thing and not humbug humbug
is the successful hoaxing of someone
really on I tried to think about that
with Edgar Allan Poe who talks about it
and you know himself and so it's a
fascinating kind of American notion like
the conman as getting over because I
think part of the notion that is
certainly the con artist or power trying
to think about is getting over is part
of the joy like he says that you know
it's not complete until the there's
because it did link did links not
complete until grin at the end you know
if you're in bed later and he fooled
someone that's when the grin have
and you're you know that's when the act
is completed and I think we still have
that and sometimes are drawn you know in
say political forums to you know people
who promise big and deliver at least
entertainment so I think we we
experience a kind of mix of feelings
when you know Barnum says there's a Fiji
mermaid behind this curtain and you go
and it's a monkey's head sewn onto a
fish's body you have to walk out and say
well why did I believe in mermaids you
know and at least and you're the kind of
the joke's on you when you have to at
least sort of participate as part of
what he's asking us to do and again I go
back to this kind of democratic idea we
also have to remember that Barnum's
first hoaxes 1835 it's a really
complicated moment where the penny press
and Technology are starting to change
media the penny press being a penny
paper versus a five cent paper and the
idea was a lot like the internet I liken
it to where you know the Internet to was
supposed to be nearly free and and
promised these great things but both the
penny press the Internet are filled with
hoaxes and that technological shift
I think it's represented by the hoax and
and lastly I think the hoax to Barnum's
hoax in 1835 it's the exact same moment
of blackface being invented and this
invention a black face sort of mirrors
all these other questions pretending to
be someone else transforming what Ralph
Ellison calls an exorcism of sort of the
white mind and white guilt over slavery
into this other form of entertainment
and so you see that those trains are
still running so there's an interesting
connection there also when you're
talking about the penny press to earn it
again because I also didn't know that he
was a journalist when he started out but
right he switches he he goes into
journalism and he is you know the same
kind of fabulous didn't that feel that
he is later but it gets him in trouble
yeah so then he switches
yeah just make your own paper
you know I think that what's interesting
too is then he runs for politics for
office later on you know and I think
that kind of link between journalism
fakery and politics is very much with us
right now and something we're thinking
about a lot yeah I could run a circus be
a journalist or run for office I think
it's more like yeah yeah same same
difference okay great
okay so let's talk a little bit more
about journalism
yeah that's okay so I thought that that
was sort of one of those interesting
parts of this or it's all interesting
but the connection you know we talk as
though fake news and the concept is
something that obviously it's an
overused term now but so it's something
we just started talking about but really
the hoax in journalism has been going on
a really long time yeah I mean with the
penny press that year 1835 PO was
publishing hoaxes and papers the most
famous sort of early hoaxes the moon
hoax happened in the same press that
later would cover joint same paper the
New York Sun that would cover choice
half so it's bound up I think into
technology I do think that we sometimes
especially like with the moon hoax want
to regard earlier generations as somehow
being naive like oh how they believe
that you know that there were people on
the moon which is what the moon hoax
claimed and I think it's because it was
well done as a hoax first of all and
second of all it mirrored back to us
what was happening on earth it was a way
of just placing right some of our
arguments and the hoax often is so
actually I thought that that might be a
good place to read because it's such an
interesting story
whoa and read about the moon hoax yeah
yeah see
oh just start with this excuse me
few people remember that in 1835 men
first walked on the moon that year
however it was all anyone could talk
about the famed reports in the Sun
described men with bat wings verse Patil
Homo unicorns and biped beavers as
viewed on the moon's surface leading to
much speculation and vast newspaper
sales in new york and the rest of the
relatively new nation all the city's
papers printed extracts or rebuttals as
with our current headline worthy hoaxes
anyone remember 2009 s Balloon Boy hoax
every outlet had to weigh in the news of
life on the moon spread like riots had
the year before when mobs of white New
Yorkers hit the streets looking for
blacks abolitionists and amalgamate errs
the name given to those who they feared
were in favor of race mixing to
intimidate beat up or worse needless to
say none of these discoveries on the
moon proved true a guy named lock locks
moon hoax would seem not just a parody
of science and faith or prank on a
gullible public but also somehow a
transference of some of the energy that
led to those riots many white readers
would rather embrace lunar man-bats than
their fellow human beings as detailed in
his book on the moon hoax the Sun and
the moon Matt Goodman writes that Locke
helped to make it more the one pit make
the Sun the one paper in the city to
come out against slavery in the state
that while it no longer sanctioned
slavery by and large supported in the
south and partook of its spoils
I'll jump ahead
if so this only supports the question of
satire that surrounds them in hook some
people say it was a satire others say it
was just kind of a large though I would
insist that intent doesn't make
something a hoax or not locks his
motives he was complex and and varied as
the canvas of the alleged moon landscape
as an anti-slavery tract the hoax is too
obscure as racist propaganda it is not
obvious enough given the extremes that
surrounded it phrenology and the rest of
the racialist sciences then coming into
being in 1830s were mere allegories in
the end finding one-to-one correlations
written on the body that determined the
subjects intelligence received lack
thereof but wait there weren't just man
bats on the moon but also superior race
of beings there that they lived on the
veil of triads indicated that there were
third highest of the three kinds of
upright beings on the moon and it's
tempting to see the lunar humanoids is
hierarchical in the ways that white
eugenicist characterized races on earth
from biped beavers metaphoric Native
Americans to wooly man-bats Negroes to
this last group in which quote nearly
all the individuals in these groups were
of larger stature than their former
specimens less dark in color and in
every respect an improved variety of the
race these last are first they were
creatures of order and subordination
interesting so moon hoax I thought the
War of the Worlds was sort of like the
first of its type but clearly no yeah no
I mean I think Locke's moon hoax is
really fascinating it's beautiful to
read and it's kind of constructed as I
talked about almost like Genesis or
something he first sees the sort of
firmament he sees the atmosphere he sees
Allah and he starts to go further and
further in and then he sees people by
the end these kind of man bats and then
the superior race of beings and it's
really brilliantly done and he also sort
of used an actual astronomer famous
astronomer Herschel who was known to be
in South Africa viewing the moon from
there from the Cape of Good Hope so he
kind of you knew enough about the
science to make it seem scientific and
in many people say that he helped invent
science fiction doing so great okay so
I'm getting a little bit obsessed the
journey yes well we can talk about it
because I think it's really important in
this moment I want you sad fake news is
sort of this this weird we're word and
what I love about Seth's book Hardin is
which is a really great book you should
get it if you don't have it it's about
you know Jason Blair one of many hoaxers
of the past 15 20 years
gosh it's longer than that almost I mean
he was 2003 for yeah but Stephen glass
was 96 mid 90s so that kind of level of
fakery I think in some of the highest
most regarded papers is really troubling
and I think that all of them involve
race in some weird way I think Stephen
glass and his hoaxing at The New
Republic
you know pretended race was all and
Jason Blair did in a different way to
yeah so I'm thinking of the connection
between I oddly enough some of the types
of fake News's fake news that has been
used politically of late and spread
through social media and fake news
pamphlet that was distributed during the
the reelection campaign Abraham
Lincoln's re-election campaign in 1864
so can you tell us that story a little
bit yeah it's called the panel is called
miscegenation and that's where that term
derives from which is I think you know
for and race-mixing and it's funny for
me now knowing that when people use it
on ironically like misogyny
anti-miscegenation law well those
existed before this pamphlet that
claimed to be for miscegenation
and Barnum himself in his humbugs of the
world talks about that as a brilliant
hoax because who would have been in
favor of that or who would have thought
Negroes were equal which is part of the
the pitch of the absurdity of this
pamphlet and it's political stamp I
think is very familiar to sort of some
of what the Russian bots for instance
did in the last election which is claim
and extreme in quotations position
ascribe it to your enemy and their then
try to sit back and watch what happens
it didn't change the election in the
case of the nation in 1864 but it seems
to have certainly had a big effect on
our elections and sort of the
weaponizing of one's worst fears or the
worst fears of the other turned against
the other person I think is chillingly
familiar yeah so I love that story
because I'm writing about the politics
of interracial relationships and the
idea that this pamphlet was sent out to
abolitionists so that asking them so
what do you think about this idea but
it's a great great thing for race races
for black and white to mix yeah right so
that they can write back and say oh yeah
that's a great idea and then you could
say see that's what they really want
right which they didn't really want I
mean which he didn't really want
yeah and the abolitionists even weren't
really like they were sort of like oh
they're like slavery is bad but I don't
know how good but I don't know about how
good that mixing is or just black people
period right but in terms of poking the
bear I mean it truly has everything that
we're talking about now including trying
to stir up make the most of conflicts
that are already there like with the
Irish right it specifically singles out
the Irish yeah as who had had you know
the draft riots about the Civil War not
wanting to serve and you know had all
this resentment and again Fox and racism
and says that they Irish would be in
proved by yeah right I mean it is I
don't know sort of I don't know if I
should say that yeah 2016 is we've got
nothing on that sort of no no I mean the
scary thing is is one of the myths that
I started to feel really troubled by as
our myth of progress which I realized
that I still even though I feel like
I've worked on some of the other myths
and got rid of them we still have this
notion that things are getting better
and different and my thinking about the
hoax realized that you know from sort of
the 1860s where you see what is it
there's another wokes that Barnum
started called the sarcassian Beauty
which is a fascinating other one we
don't have time I think to go in to all
the weights I think to the 20s you see
this kind of mix of things as it were
and then by the sort of the 1920s I
really think the hoax becomes a figure
of horror and it used to be kind of
honorific even what is it he's trying to
kind of at least have him be not
Magisterial I think it's pretty bad with
the progress notion you know across even
barnum and across the century and a half
really goes worse in my opinion and the
hoax now is not only there's more and
more intense hoaxes they also about
worse and worse things right so it's not
enough to say you know they're gonna
marry your daughters or something it's
also like you know pizza gate like like
worst horrible horrors but the hoax
always as I realize plays on our deepest
divisions and that's one of its engines
it's one of its points it's one of the
things that lets it be believed and I
started out the book thinking about why
we deceive each other but really ended
up thinking about why we believe these
things on why we believe the worst fears
about the other person and I think the
hoax really gets in there and messes
with them so yeah I mean I'm thinking
about how birth of a nation is the kind
of
that is all about a hoax like a hoax
hostess history yes but then people know
it's about the founding of the Klan as a
kind of mythic American throw it yeah by
D T W Griffith yeah I I used to teach
film and I watched that film like three
times the whole you know there's like a
shortened version I watched like the
whole three hours yeah and then the
third time I I brain imploded and I
wrote this instead I mean you know I
think that they do take a lot of I mean
it's a question I have like is cinema
where our reality shows like taking from
hoaxes or they just mirror hoaxes you
know they're not hoaxes in the true
sense it's a spectacle but it really
mirrors history and really sort of is
almost like a forgery and I think what
it's hard for us to reckon with is our
entertainment value that I think Barnum
nailed that we want to see some of these
questions worked out and it is a bit
like the more typical definition of a
monster the hoax is it's a thing that
we've created that we then want to kill
in front of us to sort of purge but
often they aren't killed they often just
live on and on like Jason and like
Friday 13 to 8 or something you know
okay so we're talk sort of really fast
forward and we talk about why you do
think it seems that you do think that
things have actually gotten worse right
not just that there's no you know there
isn't progress
but why and how so well people think
it's gotten worse lately knowing the
history not not knowing the house why do
you think it's because I'm used to just
the you know yeah it feels worse yeah um
well I think that there's many reasons
the reason I sort of stumbled across the
best explanation is a kind of narrative
crisis that we've been in what I end up
calling the age of euphemism and I think
that right now there was this a lot of
the stories that bound us
a nation came into question whether it
was the presidency and Watergate or the
truth with Vietnam or the civil rights
movement and our notion of being one
nation under God however you want to
think of it those kind of things were
being pulled apart and the hoax kind of
steps it in in that instance in in the
absence of one story a fake one of
somewhat good one will do and not even a
terribly good one just any story and I
think you see that in recent politics I
think you see that across the board in
different ways and I think it feeds the
hoax this narrative crisis we've had and
anyone who stands up and says well this
is I want to give you a direction and
this is the direction we're going in and
things are you know because things are
terrible but I can make them better is a
better story in a way then things are
okay you know it plays on the hoax the
hoax
atmosphere it's harder book to believe
everything's better or that person over
there is a person it's easier to say
that person isn't it and we've been in
that cycle I think for a while now the
only hope I have is that hoaxes get
worse in certain times and they do get
better and I think but I think they
require us not being cynical ironically
I mean I think at first I thought if we
were cynical enough we'll get past it
but the idea that everything is fake you
know which i think is the ultimate
cynical position which I think it's very
dominant now actually makes you more
susceptible to hoaxes it makes you
believe something because you're like
nothing's true then I call this seems
true to me it confirms my fears as
opposed to a kind of journalistic
skepticism that I think is really useful
we have this kind of American cynicism
what Mary Karr the writer says the
American religion now is doubt because
you want to be a sucker you want to be
like I doubt you
I want to doubt before you doubt me if
there no one has Authority
the scientists don't have authority and
don't have authority then what then what
you can tell anybody anything right I
mean I tried to make a list bringing it
for him because I saw so many
commonalities between 2016 election and
an President Trump and some of the of
hoaxes that have been part of his story
along the way right from birtherism but
that's not really right that's not
really the first one from in terms of
being a showman that the one that I
thought is kind of the funniest is him
being his own publicist yeah I was just
thinking about that I wish I'd written
more about that Baron or something yeah
Baron which he then named his son yeah
someone just made that connection for me
I was like wow that's amazing
yeah you don't have to say anything
about that it writes itself or saying
when he first wanted to be on the Forbes
list that he was worth hundreds of
millions and apparently he was worth
five but I mean that's I mean you know I
think that there's a very American
notion in that you know we value success
but we more than success we value the
appearance of success and it's why you
know like there's there's something
almost admirable in in the most pure if
we can stand back and you know it's like
why rappers show money and videos you
know like it's not because they have
money necessarily like the cars are
rented but it's like here I have money
and then you make money because people
think you have money it's kind of this
alchemy of and you know even a painter
like jean-michel Basquiat who I think
was really brilliant about such things
he started drawing money on his
paintings and he said like him then I
started making all this money after that
and it's this kind of alchemy that
they're trying for I think it's very
almost American certainly it's
african-american in its improvisational
qualities for best God I mean I think he
is trying to say fake it to you make it
right
Wow I mean yeah right it's always doing
like that's why you put that in your
video and then eventually hopefully you
have made the next video you might might
be your money great so we should do that
right now let's pull out our wads yeah
big bang take little bank it's
interesting also how just sort of
switching to the positive component or
at least the positive functions that
hoax is conserved so sort of the myth
not I think of it as sort of a hoax of
American exceptionalism mmm it's really
interesting because that coexists the
idea that America is this land of
equality and absolute freedom sure and
it's being founded on that at the same
time it's completely dependent on
slavery right which is the ultimate
taking away of freedom but that myth
allows us to feel good about American
identity right but even more that's sort
of like not quite a positive so it's
yeah we hear rise some of the most
successful conmen absolutely perform
president Trump so are there I was
thinking about popular culture and how
we love like when you see them in the
movies or in television stories I I
wanted to write even more about Gatsby
who I think is is a perfect example or
an a fictional sense of this kind of
American art of reinvention which I do
think plays into our notions of hoaxing
and why we sort of can tolerate some
level of it or entertained by it and I
think Gatsby is a brilliant table about
that because he reinvents himself as
Gatsby you know once you say sport he
calls everyone good sport and this idea
of him sort of adopting that it's still
yet not enough you know he kicked and
it's a fascinating film that I think you
know we were talking just before about
Mad Men right you know that to me is the
other sort of modern version where you
take it
man's identity and you're always faking
but maybe in that you become yourself
you know and he does right sir at madmen
yeah
he's he a hero or an antihero Wow you
tried to make me write another book
about this aren't you
I mean you know I think I think that
he's a kind of American antihero I think
sure I mean he is it can we give
spoilers I mean how many years has it
been
Wow we're safe I'm sure that people
haven't watched it here but you know I
think that his sort of arc into American
iconography the VW Bug the Coca Cola all
the you know tobacco I mean tobacco and
the tobacco thing is almost more
emblematic of this literally American
product that that's native to us and
that then is being sold as this you know
cure-all and even though they know it's
not and that that kind of is a perhaps
even more deadly metaphor than in Gatsby
for what fakery can do and eat at you so
you know we have this beautiful heroic
character sort of heroic serve an entire
deceptive character and the Lucky Strike
account where they're trying to sell
tobacco as being healthy sure maybe this
was toasted yeah it's toasted so you
know I mean this you know there's much
like that I mean we have these
contradictions and what I was what it
was interesting to me is the way that
the hoax because it's fake tells us the
truth because once it's gone away and
revealed we are only left with our
belief so we have to kind of reckon with
that and I thought that especially with
say Stephen glass I mean there are other
people I think this is examples of but
his hoaxes were so pin to race yeah why
did we believe them or that certain
people believe them why James
try was he believed as this figure when
he you know faked his first memoir and
then a second memoir which is called my
friend Leonard has anyone read my friend
Leonard my friend yeah you did
what's crazy is so the first book of
course he lied about being in prison
when he was in jail for like a couple
hours but the beginning of my friend
Leonard is in prison like month three
yeah so the whole of my friend Leonard
is just a total fabrication and the
beginning of it is him getting in a
fight with a big black guy named Porter
house you know so this is all from his
imagination of course and then he
teaches Porter house how to read because
of course Porter house can't read as big
black guys in jail that you make up
can't and could anyone tell me the guess
if you know don't say what book that he
uses to teach Porter house kind of read
correct Huck Finn what's funny is I
think it's about seventy five percent
that people guess yeah correctly I'm the
only other options Uncle Tom's Cabin but
that would be yeah so he had to move it
up a few decades or week but you know
that kind of I think I call them a you
know a kind of abolitionist on safari
kind of thing yeah
and I think that that quality might save
your ass yeah I mean of course and so
once that's revealed
you know we're stuck with just his
belief or our belief or his invention
that you know why did that pass for true
and so in that reckoning I think we have
to think a lot about these kind of deep
American stories a lot of what passes
for true passes for true because it's or
we want it to be true either because
it's self aggrandizing to the person and
they're attractive or it self
aggrandizing to us or into the american
identity or to this idea of this
prisoner who's that so far and i guess
it's two fries yeah right because he's
the hero but I also think it's because
it's it's super tragic and messed up you
know it speaks to
our need for what I start the book with
all the American public wants is a
tragedy with a happy ending you know and
and that idea of the tragic but then at
the very end you know is I think much
more what it's about so it isn't simply
that it's a grand izing excuse me it's
exotic it's questionable it's troubling
but then at the end you get a little bit
of Reading Is Fundamental so there's one
person that is in this book that I have
an aversion to talking about but I would
love to hear
oh no you talk about can you guess I can
guess what I want to say actually I
wrote down her name because what is next
week
Nikki the new name Rachel Dolezal she
has a reason yes she's a new name now
you know I finished my essay and luckily
didn't have to read about her anymore
oh so tell them about it but I'll have a
name because the name is such again
stealing identity it's Nicki Minaj or
something listen no I'll tell you in a
second it's African sounding African
sounding that's well as you remembered
that Rachel Dolezal was the white Ichi
Amaury Diallo Huck Finn would be proud I
guess what
she almost troubles me most you know
because she is a white woman who of
course darkened her skin changed her
hair and claimed to be black then was
the head of the n-double a-c-p in Oregon
I mean she couldn't have done that in
Harlem where the Schomburg Center is
that won't worked you know so I think
that she like picked her place to do
this and I wonder if it's a little like
when Gene Wilder's in blackface and
what's that movie Silver Streak yeah and
everyone all the black people know but
you know I wonder about that like what
was happening with that but my real
trouble with her is of course she got
much more attention for being not black
and black people often get she was on
The Today Show a whole bunch of time
and then a week later was the Charleston
murders and it kind of pushed her off
the whatever front page or first second
half hour of today's show but I started
thinking that and I end up writing about
this that the the killer and her both
had the similar kinds of
misunderstandings of blackness and that
they both thought of blackness as this
tragic thing because Rachel Dolezal was
attracted to the horror
you know the blackness as being like you
know tragic and his and I redact his
name in the book on purpose
his point of view couldn't be swayed by
these very much people praying in front
of him and praying with him he couldn't
then change his input you know and I
feel like she too misunderstood
blackness as tragic and the differences
she wanted to be that he want to murder
that but both have this similar problem
with it but I really wanted to think
about aloud about this problem with race
this wish to be someone else and when it
occurs in the book it occurs more like
toward the plagiarism chapter because
there's a kind of plagiarizing of
another person's pain that you see over
and over again in the 20th century
whether it's fake Native Americans which
someone called pretend Ian's which is
great term or you know like fake black
folks or blackface you know you have two
poles in blackface it's tragic or comic
and ultimately they're the same thing
there's no tragedy that isn't ridiculous
and no comedy that isn't a little bit
sad really
Manny being the song from the jazz
singer being sort of the ultimate
example of that as opposed to say the
Blues or actual african-american
inventions which know that within that
you're laughing to keep from crying and
and they aren't maudlin they're in fact
deeply funny you know you've been a good
old wagon but you done broke down is a
philosophy you know it's a way of
thinking about the
old and provides a kind of answer in a
way to name pain to move past it and
that's so different than plagiarizing
pain and living in it and trying to make
it your existence one is a form of
resistance and one is a form of I don't
know what so there you mentioned the
nice lady who in every Church like
there's one like nice white lady who's
never blocked her to write but she never
tries to claim yeah yeah my church at
least but Rachel wants to show up and
not just claim it yes you want to be the
center of it and that and the question I
have is why do you if you feel black
what she says why do you have to look
black right also you know in the in the
telling I'm really interested in the
telling of her story because one of the
things that you talk about a lot of
people don't when they talk about Rachel
Dolezal is the fact that she makes up so
much backstory she's not content to just
say okay I want to look black I want
people to believe that I'm black and I
want to be able to tell authorities but
she makes up an entire tragic backstory
for herself so her level of deception is
so deep and that that's still it's
literally stolen pain yeah I mean I
think that's the difference I mean
sometimes people ask me what's the
definition of the hoax you know I think
there's a number of them I give him the
book but one that I sort of think of
return to is it's lying with
explanations you know that it keeps
going on and on so this the more I read
and the more I saw that's not surprising
you know she people often have to invent
not just their tragic backstory but like
others around them a whole host of
people someone like JT Leroy who
pretended to be a man pretending to be a
woman you know there's a whole you know
it was only tragic and again I returned
to this American notion would we have
what she have gone as far if she said
you know I was a black person you know
think back that wouldn't have been as
you know selling
for her she complains about colorism and
being beaten lord I mean they're purple
but the color was the color wash I love
all the names that came up I thought she
was gonna be a joke on black Twitter
which I talked about and we came up with
all these great names for the inevitable
biography autobiography and I don't
remember who said their eyes were
watching Oprah I think you made up a few
th like me was one of mine I guess like
me I think I did I do the Oprah why am I
on Oprah and then I think Victor Laval's
had an imitate the imitation of
imitation of life or something so that's
kind of um I felt like that maybe that
was a little bit more of a personal
story because the voice seemed different
yeah the writing style yeah it was a
toward the end and as I say in the book
I thought I was done you know I'd sort
of catalog these hoaxes and I then I got
asked for a book by Jasmine Ward the
fire this time to write an essay and I
wrote on Dolezal and partially I was
riding out of fury that I had to keep
thinking about this you know and
partially would happen for me is I
realized I'm told my editors I said look
I can't I got to stop because there's
gonna be another hoax next week if I
keep going yeah and sort of wants all
the stuff with fake news happen I
literally just would like add a sentence
because so much of it I had already sort
of if not predicted then sort of
prophesized or somehow thought of in
some way and so Dolezal was like one
extra thing almost a straw too many but
I I then and then my editor kept saying
you need to put it in the book or should
you and I was like he was very gentle
yeah smart but I was like I don't think
so I don't think so and then I was like
oh I have to because she really and she
really helped end the book and tell this
kind of story that goes on and on and
let me be a bit more personal and I mean
I think at one point I say I could read
from that part and then we could turn to
questions from you guys I'll just read a
little from that essay it kind of jumps
around on purpose
it's called blacker than thou it was
never easy for me I was born a poor
black child the beginning of Steve
Martin's the jerk still makes me laugh
with his twist on once upon a time the
dissonance between what we know of the
white comedian Martin his relative
success and its obviously false
declaration sends up not only the tragic
showbiz biography but the corny black
one in both of the worser the better it
also suggests his characters
transformation his overcoming after all
he's clearly white now not to mention
his current lot in which he's a witch
he's smudged bummy
apparently destitute his isn't black
face but his face half greased is
certainly part of the effect it's a
familiar one in other words to black
people used to watching white people
only claim blackness as a poor me stance
now why does this jerk remind me of
Rachel Dolezal here's the thing about
talking about when Rachel Dolezal is
fraud first broken it was simply a joke
on black Twitter which as you probably
know isn't a separate app but I
identified so my favorite Twitter titles
from the navigable anticipated memoir
their eyes were watching Oprah that
one's mine imitation of imitation life
from Victor love all blackish like me
mine too
now things done got serious there's a
long tradition of passing of crossing
the racial line usually going from black
to white you could say it was started
like this country by Thomas Jefferson
one of the best things about being black
is that barring some key exceptions it's
not a volunteer position you can't just
wish on a dark star and become black
it's not paid either it's more like a
long internship with a chance of
advancement
after the killings in Charleston several
things happen
Dolezal story went back to being merely
ridiculous talk-show has moved on to
something else
and those who somehow will Dolezal
sublime were treated flags flew at
half-staff except the Confederate flag
on South Carolina Statehouse grounds it
took a black woman
Brittany Newsome they climb up and take
that down
they gave the assignment to a black man
to raise the rebel flag back up like
Sally Hemings he might not have minded
but he certainly couldn't have refused
ok that's a good place to that Sally
Hemings Rachel yes you're gonna ask me
as though history was just making this
stuff up for you I mean sort of like the
world was sort of conspiring to make
this this particular moment
I mean election of 2008 all delassalle
2015 the election news 20s yeah I mean
I'm really glad that I had said before
then that I would stop you know in the
summer of 16 I said you know I gotta
finish this book because there's gonna
be another hoax next week and the
election was on my birthday so I had to
go away and like write this cota but it
was kind of more a horrible thing to be
write about you know and I say that in
the coda like I hated I realized you
know then that I wanted kind of tragic
story with a happy ending I wanted this
to end in and kind of well things are
looking up you know but you know CNN had
a year of the hoax it had you know
declared all these things about hoaxes
in a few years in a row and then they
just gave up
you know the Washington Post had a hoax
tracker they just gave up you know it
just got really dark there for a while
as it were
I feel a little more hopeful now that I
think I do in the end of the book but I
think that's more because I think people
are starting to talk about this problem
and I hope my book helps that so now you
guys have to do some work so Kevin I
have a question for you it's someone who
writes nonfiction writes poetry do you
have a separate process for doing that
and how or does working in one genre
influence and interact with with
together yeah
thanks I'd say yes it does it's not so
director obvious to me how definitely
nonfiction requires a different kind of
attention poems though I think poems are
intense and can do they generally you
can think about in a session or look
through a manuscript in a book like this
you have to just it's everyday plugging
away and you know I revised it quite a
bit over the years and have to turn this
giant chip around like you know two
times a year took a lot out of me
but you have to be sort of there
physically for it even with computers
and all that and what was interesting is
it requires a lot more reading the same
amount of introspection but I really
especially for a book about hoaxes I
want there to be you know notes and a
bibliography and believe me there were
books I read about hoaxes that had no
notes you know and I was like this feels
like a hoax it sounds like it's so weird
and you know I admire you as a
journalist making that really clear
here's who I talk to here's what I
listen to
here's what this is from and that's you
know it's not just I think people
sometimes dismiss that as sort of
intellectualism when really it's the
trail that someone hooks into footnote
number 50 and wants to find out more
you're laying out you know how you got
there
and I you know I'm super you know my
process not like a share of it like I
reading these totally disparate things
that don't seem to make sense together
even sometimes to me but once I follow
my nose there they are and I want you to
be able to to and maybe you'll come to a
very different conclusion that said I
think both bunk and my new book Brown
which is just out is a book that of
poems but they're both interested in
history and the way history touches us
all and and that were part of history
whether we admit it or not and and that
kind of connection I think I almost felt
maybe because of bunk I felt more
comfortable with in brown but at one
point there was sort of the public poems
in Brown the poems about athletes or
Arthur Ashe or you know Lead Belly
and then there were sort of poems about
me and my love of music or my love of
sports and my growing up in Kansas in
part and living in the south when I was
writing it so my goal by the end was to
make those things together and I think
that bunk sort of helped me understand
how to tell a history in a certain way
and to not keep those strands so
separate yeah so um so there's some
obvious parallels you know going back in
history as you noted and I'm just
wondering what you might think is
different is there is there anything
about the way things unfold now the way
we communicate the technology we have is
there anything about the way that these
hoaxes are perpetuated now that is
different and is that in some ways more
or less hopeful did you say hopeful at
the end yeah I I did so I was I gave you
an opportunity yeah well the two things
I think is that hoaxes can be propagated
faster just with the click and suddenly
you know it's a simple thing
by a guy in a basement or say for
nefarious reasons in Russia and then
suddenly it's targeted to specific
people as opposed to everyone and I
think that is really troubling and I
don't think we've quite reckoned with
that I sort of was starting to say in my
book you know here's what technology
could do and its problems I wouldn't
have thought that the hoax could be kind
of weaponized in a way that it clearly
was so and it's clear and clear every
day but what interests me is that that
targeted exactly these same divisions I
also think if sometimes can be you know
I try to say in the book that
journalists catch journalistic hoaxes
the internet Kicks catches Internet
hoaxes you know it's not simply that the
Internet is a vast place of conspiracies
and dead ends though sometimes it feels
that way so that is important and I do
think that at the same time you know
it's really harder now for a hoax to go
away completely sometimes and I think
you've seen people now start to try to
say in journalism include like
birtherism you know the claim sometimes
gets reported as if it's a claim without
saying that it's a false claim and I
think you see people now much more
saying this false claim is was repeated
you know but it can be I think harder to
to dissuade people who don't want to be
dissuaded I was on a talk radio thing
and a guy called in and he well two guys
called in one called in and he said he
had started a poetry prize and there was
it was sort of like the March Madness
there were brackets and people got
really excited and invested in who won
and then he declared a winner and then
he also admitted that he had written all
the poems they were in the bracket and I
was like you know that's pretty wild you
know and I'm like yeah you got some
splaining to do you know no wonder
people upset at you but then someone
else called and they said I met him in a
separate program but they said oh well
the reason that there's so many more
hoaxes is because Obama passed that law
I was like what
talking about it's like the law where
you can just hoax people now and that's
legal I mean we laugh about it but this
person didn't just think like it you
know we're completely serious and you
know in a weird way was was not in a
hoax in the sense that they were being
hoaxes but they were not operating in
that realm they hadn't been sort of D
hoaxed yet and that was really
interesting
and then the commentator was like what
do you think of this law
you know but said you know like what is
the name of that law you know you have
to be able but the our capacity to say
oh here's the name of the law it's bills
back to sources if we we don't have a
good sense of sources and a good sense
of what is a good source and a lot of
things can seem the same online and I
think that you know physics I mean
civics class helps and I feel like we
lost that and libraries I think are
these great place where you get neutral
information and provide you know I work
in one so I think that you can find
anything there and I actually a lot more
than the Internet
thanks for your question hey so I I'm
interested in the whole the 1830s and
sort of yeah you because you say
democracy and you just sort of a thing
that was part of this and you know of
course that's like right after Andrew
Jackson's elected it was crazy populist
election where it's the first guy who
wasn't some serious guy he's a guy who
believes it's pistol around what so what
was it about that more like the the idea
of the connection between populism and
democracy and how that lends itself to
hoaxes and yeah and this loss of we
don't have the king anymore but then
that means we don't have authority
figures anymore tell us things I think
you know there were hoaxes when Kings
were around of course but the hoax would
usually be like that person's a prince
you know I'm a lost Prince you know I'm
the lost I arena you know that was very
common but obviously in the States you
don't see that as much I was really
interested in the ways that that played
out almost with
and you see it even now with a kind of
claim toward nativeness both like I
belong here but also kind of often
literal I am native you know by
especially white folks saying that they
were and that really interested me as a
kind of tactic going back to the Boston
Tea Party you know and and what it meant
to put on this mask an American mask and
how did that play out over time I do
think that populism I find an in exact
term and this is just me personally I
mean populism gets used to refer to a
kind of elite bashing but by elites so
you know by people are you know richer
than God and so it becomes a kind of
strange term you know growing up in
Kansas there was a kind of different
notion of populism I feel like the kind
of farmer based like you have your
opinion I have mine let's you know make
good fences good neighbors kind of thing
so I don't know I'd feel not totally
settled on how populism plays into
except for there's this idea of the mob
versus the crowd versus the populist
that you see play out in the 1830s a lot
and around riots around the penny press
itself and I don't know how that is with
us now certainly we're being in it and
being a fish in the water not knowing
how wet we are it's hard to talk about
but I can't imagine that we won't look
back and think about black lives matter
and that movement on one hand and then
it's seeming opposite and the other and
how that the hoax kind of knitted those
things together or try to make sense of
it but I don't have a good total
response for you it's a big question
don't try to make me write a third book
about this stuff I like it hey thanks I
have two that I think are related is
there a history of fact-checking and
sort of calls for Corrections and then
current day just given the technology
they sort of talked about I'm thinking
about the tipping point when we all
recognize something as a hoax yeah does
it take an authority figure usually
white to say that or is it snopes.com
and we all sort of move on like what's
yeah are you saying now or in general I
think yeah it just seems like oh of
course that was a hoax but who decided
like how do we come to that well it's a
little like I guess what I would say
it's always a hoax and the question is
when is it recognized I mean why now are
there like more flat-earthers than there
were well and I always asked like why is
that happening now not just like because
I think the world was is round and you
know Kyrie Irving is like I'm a flat
earth or you know he did that to
manipulate the media like he was making
a point
but that's so crappy I mean you know
it's sort of like you know Kanye West
all over my timeline and that like loops
you know no I have a hard time with if
you hoax and then pull the shade away
are you still not a hoaxer you know I
think you actually are a hoaxer that's
the definition of a hoaxer so I have a
hard time sort of letting people off the
hook especially about what they host
about you know and and admitting you
hoax doesn't get you out of that and
that's what I was trying to draw
attention to with these hoaxes about
race and then the larger kind of
question is of course that race itself
is a kind of hoax which is to say a fake
thing pretending to be true this doesn't
mean racism is fake quite the opposite
and I think it's almost it's
intractability comes from that it isn't
from this real thing so the first part
of your question I actually don't know
the answer to it's a great idea I do
think that I became really interested in
objectivity
ilysm which I do I don't know if that
helps or hurts us as to debunk these
things because yeah it's a fairly recent
phenomenon objectivity and other ideas
of journalists journalism don't have it
exactly it's a kind of American notion
right as opposed to say accuracy which i
think should be the point of all
journalism but it isn't objective to
present like two sides of climate change
debate but you see that happen regularly
on shows especially it makes good TV you
know or back when Oprah would like
entertain the clan for like an hour you
know I think that there's this kind of
weird mix between accurate attention and
then also ignoring the total crap and
how do we balance that I'm not sure sir
birtherism right like do things kept
debunks because even after you got an
apology well I mean it was kind of a
weekly a lot of people are winking but a
lot of people still believe it right but
but birtherism was never you know the
idea that Obama wasn't born it was never
about what it was about so to kind of
like say like can we disprove that you
know like that is there's never gonna be
a proof enough to say that a black guy
belongs and and if we start with kind of
that trouble idea I think would be
better off I mean you know if Morgan
Freeman can't have convinced us that
there are black presidents and how can
Obama I mean you know I think that
there's this kind of weird fact of that
and I ended up writing about that in my
review of Tana hasty Coates is we were
eight years in power because I was
really interested in this black
president idea and so is he you know
he's really passionate about that and
then I think the thing he said most
powerfully in that book is that Trump is
the first white president he says and
what does that mean you know
and that these two things go together
and one follows the other the thing that
really convinces me what you're saying
right that it's obviously never really
about the birth certificate or where he
was born is that Trump said at the time
because he's number one birth or okay
well I'll pay I'll give a charity this
millions of dollars if you show me your
transcript right right because you're an
affirmative action cousin and that's how
you got in well and also then this same
person won't show their taxes right so
it's never about what it's about I mean
it's about power and I mean I said that
about plagiarism to plagiarism about
power it's about aspiration there ends
up being a lot of Harvard plagiarists
that I talked about and what interests
me is only that seems the only
explanation for something like Melania
Trump plagiarizing Michelle Obama's
speech I mean that's the most crazy
moment that would have sunk anything
else but it was you know like she didn't
own her words and that was because but
it's also more nefarious than that I can
steal from you but also I need to steal
from you that's a really deep yeah so I
work with I've worked with youth in
different capacities and I'm also just
thinking about what that means in terms
of like history that's being taught I'm
thinking of have so much of our
education systems like a history classes
it's completely like white wah
whitewashed versions of what slavery
looked like and that idea of our
education system can sometimes be a hoax
in itself and that not everything is
relevant and true and I'm thinking of
how I hear from students or people in
general ho racism has ended slavery has
ended and when you look at the
incarceration rates of you know African
men how much you know how much there is
so I'm just thinking of your thoughts on
that and how youth or even for me I
think about how to go navigate about
unlearning these things you know I'm
learning these hoaxes and trying to
better understand the truth of it all
yeah it's a big question a good one you
know I work at an
the Schomburg Center for research or my
culture and I feel like there's many
reasons for it to be but it's initiating
reason was that one of our founders
Arturo Schaumburg was told as a young
man he's black Puerto Rican and Puerto
Rico that there was no black history and
he sought out to prove that person wrong
and he amassed 10,000 vindicating
evidences he said and but what's
interesting is he also is trying to go
beyond what he calls this the idea of
firsts you know which I think sometimes
we reach to to explain but I don't think
we should you know it's a tough thing
because I what I love about their tour
of Shambhala is what he when he writes
about it and the Negro digs up his past
his famous essay which you can get
online pretty easily he's thinking in
the 1920s but some of the same questions
that dog us now why we should study the
past why we should know it and for me
history is the way to kind of help
people navigate and what you're saying
is what if history is is taught as bunk
and what if history is falsified I think
that's all the more reason you have we
have places like Schaumburg which now
those 10,000 items are 10 million items
and we have their evidence that you can
see for yourself and you know I sound a
little like Barnum but for for different
reasons you know like you come see the
documents you come and study for
yourself and see and I think it's so
important for young people to see their
history not just you know hear about it
or read about it
that unmediated kind of history I think
really speaks to them now what I think
libraries and archives like Schaumburg
do or provide context for that so when
we have a discussion a conversation
about race that whole you know century
almost of history 93 years we've been in
Harlem since 1925 speaks of - so when
people come and we have a black comic
book festival it's not like we just
invented black heroes you know last week
or with Black Panther or and in that
when we're having the black comic
well people went up stairs to see the
Black Power exhibition and saw actual
the Black Panthers from the 60s you know
and that kind of history I think is so
important for people to see firsthand it
gets me really excited because I see
what happens when you put a kid who
thinks they're not part of a history
book because there's two ways history
books I think can screw with us one is
you're excluded one is you're included
but so unimportant that you think you
are yeah I mean it's almost worse you
know like you know when when they're
true Schomburg was being told that he
could prove instantly you're wrong
here's two books you're wrong but when
you have a book that is artfully trying
to you know disenfranchise you from
within
I do think you have to work a little
hard but I also think it's important to
go to these places and I hope there's
one near you where you can take folks
and show them this history walk around
Boston is a place filled with everything
from Phyllis Wheatley the Crispus
Attucks way back when who speak to these
long history of revolution and change so
you know how we're working on for
instance a hip hop curriculum and I
think that's going to tell help young
people where they are
think about this history and so you know
to me it's it's a combination of shows
in the past but also connect to them and
they're present and where they live and
help bring them that's how I learned and
came to it because a lot of what I
learned I didn't learn in school thank
you thanks hi this question is kind of
for both you and professor Bell and goes
along with that question it's like if
you look at someone like the political
science literature it's a little bit
more pessimistic about presenting facts
to countering hoaxes yeah so how do we
draw people in to the things like the
Schomburg Center or maybe some people
who are more resistant to listening to
the other side like well I mean is the
point of history to try to convince
people who
want to be convinced I'm curious yeah
what no that's a part of my question
it's like is it even worth trying to get
Oh some people just totally unreachable
and the and my other question is
somebody who studied poetry is how is
this book if at all has it informed your
writing your poetry now sure let's start
you can answer that first part so some
of the political science literature has
been really pessimistic about the
possibility of persuasion happening but
there have been recent studies that have
shown that there are strategies so
sometimes the presentation of facts over
and over again that are contrary to
somebody's prior beliefs makes people
dig in further right because they feel
defensive of that but there are other
times right and there are strategies as
Kevin said you need to present if you're
gonna repeat the lie first of all
repeating the lie can reinforce it if
you're gonna repeat it you have to frame
it as a false claim and not as you know
a claim that's that's made or lay coffee
was a cognitive linguist suggests that
rather than repeat the claim you could
just actually say what the truth is
right what crazy idea that's insane yeah
and so rather than spreading and
reinforcing reminding people of the
false claim you talk about you know
Obama being born and in Hawaii right and
and his biography and just you you say
you tell the story that doesn't you know
remind them oh you don't believe this
right but you know you're you just sort
of like you don't confront anything that
is causing the problem in the first
place yeah I mean
I think about this sometimes with bunk
because you know it's a book that I hope
by the end you you know I wasn't just
trying to convince someone who didn't
believe the story I also was trying to
uncover a story that might not have been
known and I had the sort of experience
and maybe I wanted to kind of recreate
that of starting out thinking well maybe
the hoax it seems to me a lot about race
and by the end I was like oh my god not
another racial hoax you know and like or
a hoax that you know it seemed like the
same thing by the end even in places
that seem far far flung from it and so I
want to kind of recreate that feeling
and it was importantly the structure of
the book so that people understood and
discovered with me and I guess that's
another way of how I try to frame these
things is you know not just here it is
you need to believe in but also like
here's how to discover it and also
teaching people how to discover things
what is a source you know here are the
sources of the backcheck go you know
here's some links I think you see this
in a positive way with something like
the Charleston syllabus say where people
are not simply saying like here's this
event here's why it's bad but here's
also a context for understanding this
event and I'm not sure how much that
works but I think it's a really good
effort and important part of it in terms
of my own work you know I think poetry
and prose aren't so far apart I don't
know if I would have said that a few
years ago I do think that what I like
about bunk and people have said this to
me is that it feels like for me a poet's
book in the sense that I'm making these
connections between things that may not
always be obvious and to me that's what
a poem does is it takes one things and
says it is the other and it's like the
other if not just make that leap and
those connections I think are really
important and what I tried to stress in
both of the books
I tell you it was a secret helpful place
of persuasion though that I think it's
not commercial for you because you
mentioned the term edutainment right
like this terrible thing but I mean
Sesame Street is edutainment like it
actually I mean the word edutainment
because Boogie Down Productions put a
record called edutainment and like 89
anyway but you know people can use
fiction write fiction teaches and I'm
just going to use fiction to fiction
sort of like reduces the barriers
reduces counter arguing so people aren't
on alert
I mean I think it's not fiction by the
hidden figures I think film for me you
know like I feel like when I rewatched a
tree sing with my son and it just is an
amazing weld on film that sweeps you
along and if you don't feel anything
when she's like I have to go a mile to
the bathroom right then maybe you have a
piece missing I don't want to talk to
you but you know like that's where I I'm
not against persuasion and quite the
opposite and in fact the thing that I
came to realize and I argue in the book
is that not hoaxes don't just hurt facts
but they heard the imagination and they
hurt our ability to believe that
something made up can move us you know
and we we 10 is kind of accompanies this
autobiographical biographical impulse
that I think especially as Americans we
have and you see it more and more
what sort of nonfiction means and you
know there's nothing like a good story
or a good tale and that's very American
- and and it has truth in it yeah the
opposite well that's what my first books
about it's about the truth
so we end with that we have anymore we
should end with the truth all right
thanks everybody
[Applause]